I studied economics at Cambridge
University um coming out of there in
2012 was a very exciting time in machine
learning um we saw the Dropout algorithm
had just come out um like tensor flow
was being released uh there was a lot of
excitement around machine
learning and um I quickly found myself
using machine learning techniques uh at
my first company that I started which
was called seamless capital uh and this
was an algorithmic trading firm and we
were using uh neural networks and uh uh
decision trees to predict the outcomes
in sports and then we would uh we would
place bets on these predictions and we
made money and uh it was very successful
I kind of spent 10 years growing up this
this very um AI machine learning uh
intensive sort of uh Quant Trading Group
and then uh recently I you know about 3
years ago I turned
30 and that was a kind of pivotal uh
moment for me and I sort of I decided do
I want to keep doing algorithmic trading
or did I want to build something uh
bigger and three years ago it was clear
to people involved in AI that uh large
language models were going to be a very
impactful
technology um and I thought it was going
to be a tremendous wave and I thought
it's really going to change the way uh
consumers interact uh with
technology um and at the time it was
really just it was like open AI had just
released GPT uh like three I think I
think I think they'd announced gpt3 but
you couldn't you couldn't use it you had
to join like a weit list um and they
they' shared the weights to their gpt2
models um and so I really wanted to get
hold of these this like um these llms uh
using this Transformers architecture but
it was quite difficult to like just get
it running and actually see what it
could do um and I just thought it was
really weird that the all this cool
technology was being built at Google
Deep Mind at open AI but it was very
hard to get one's hands on right um and
then I discovered hugging face and
hugging face had like these burp models
which weren't very good and it was
obvious that there was going to come a
day when more and more people were
training their own language models it
wasn't just going to be Google and open
AI forever there was going to come a day
when when many many people were doing it
and from my experience in machine
learning through algorithmic trading was
I saw the I saw a world
where it's not the case that there's one
big hedge fund that dominates all
markets but instead in the financial
world you see it's a very fragmented
Market where each hedge fund specializes
in a unique asset class right so for
example Bridgewater it will be like a
macro hedge fund and it will it will
analyze the world and look at things at
a certain time Horizon you know a lot of
people will hear about Warren Buffett he
he buys a stock and he wants to hold it
for at least 10 years and then all the
way at the other end of the spectrum you
get these high frequency Traders and and
that their models that they're using are
fundamentally predicting the where this
price of this asset is going to be in
maybe uh 5 Seconds time so they're
buying and selling and buying and
selling very very very fast and and I
just thought well this language model
technology is really no different than
the sort of Technology we see in
financial markets um you know
information um is very is Central to
both so in financial markets you're
trying to gather all the information
that's relevant and to set a price um
and we see that that machine learning in
a is fantastic at at at really Gathering
a huge body of data um and then really
uh using using that well to create
the best estimate possible um and so I
just thought it's very clear that that
the world that we live in is is
structured in a way that all the
information these experts are
distributed and it's going to be a day
where teams of very smart industrious
people come together and they they they
build expert models that are very good
at a single specific thing and this and
sorry and and and like the simplest the
simplest way I kind of viewed it from a
consumer perspective would be well maybe
one day there's there's a little company
that builds just a recipe Ai and
there'll be another company that builds
a you know a joke Ai and there's another
one and then you need a platform for all
these to come together that consumers
could then uh interact with I wonder do
you fundamentally see AI as a kind of
search engine or as a reasoning engine
and what I mean by that question is open
AI pitched that they have this general
intelligence and then they released gpts
which made it seem quite domain specific
and data Centric so what's your view on
that I think it's very very clear that
they operate like a search engine and
not a reasoning uh engine that's that's
current the current architecture the
current algorithms the way they work um
I really think there are kind of two
camps um that are excited about AI
you've got the the AI researchers people
that have been working in Ai and know
this space for a long long time
um and we've all seen how uh Tesla and
elas sort of every year they say
autonomous cars are just around the
corner and I'm old enough to remember
when uh you know these these neural
networks that were that were first being
used um to understand video and to um to
try and solve uh these like autonomous
agent tasks uh it really looked very
convincing that they would just they
would surpass Human Performance uh
pretty quickly and yet a decade later
what we've seen is this repeated Trend
where um there'll be like an
architecture and across a series of
benchmarks as the architecture gets
refined it very rapidly gets better and
then people get very excited and they
sort of do this linear extrapolation
they go okay well we're just around the
corner but actually it doesn't follow
this like linear um path instead it
follows like an S curve
and and it's it's it it tops out at a
certain level and it seems that most of
machine learning has has always topped
out around Human Performance and so with
these autonomous cars they very quickly
got to be about as good as a human
driver in a lot of cases but that final
just just that final 5% of performance
all these tiny little edge cases um
turned out to be very very uh tricky
yeah and I think there's two components
of that the benchmarks are are broken
because they are in some some way
bottlenecked by um examples of humans
doing things but also the way they are
trained um is based on examples of
humans doing things perhaps with
language and people like Shane leg talk
about the distinction between um being
parasitic on data and doing your own
searching you know in order to get
superum performance what do you think
about
that I think we need to speak about
which human we're thinking of and I
think it's very clear that
like with AI I think three years ago if
you interact with gpt2 I've got children
at home and so I always think of it in
terms of IQ or intelligence of a human
and I think it's clear that gpt2 if you
interacted with that and you interacted
with a three-year-old they're kind of
the similar sort of level um and then
you get to gpt3 and it's maybe like a
six-year-old or something and then with
GPT
4 um and and and 3.5 and chap chap GPT
um I think a lot of people get they over
it's easy to overinflate their abilities
um because they've really been optimized
to human preferences um and so they say
things that humans quite
like uh but it doesn't really reflect a
deep understanding of the world and you
know we're all familiar with ways in
which you can trip uh you know these GPT
models up a four-digit multiplication is
is very very difficult um and many
things we would consider reasoning it is
simply you know it can't do a very good
job of and you know my my opinion is gp4
is maybe around like a 9-year-old or
something and so what we see is we see
okay we we're going up up up this curve
and where is going to top out and I
would guess if I had to you know had had
to place a I think it'll top out around
like high school level maybe like a
15-year-old and then we can think well
would would we deem having the
intelligence of an average 15y old would
that be would that constitute
AGI would that constitute superhuman you
know and I think for some humans it is
super you know there's absolutely a
percentage of the population for which
GPT will be um extraordinarily helpful
and there'll be another section um
through which we'll be waiting a little
bit longer for more algorithmic
Innovations before the it's Supra uh
human yeah I I agree with that I I think
language is like thought space and
there's a super organism and we're kind
of um embedding all of these human
thoughts into our language and most
humans are dumb most humans just rinse
and repeat the same thoughts that are
already embedded in the space it's only
the the really smart people on the edges
on the Frontiers who are actually
percolating up new thoughts into that
space yeah yeah um so will we're a
little bit tight on time so um you you
spoke about seamless which is your your
first business but you have now built a
$450 million startup with I think only
about 12 people you're' spoken about
Talent density I'm a startup founder
myself which you know so I'm very
jealous and I think you've got some very
interesting things to say as well about
how you know there's this exponential um
increase of friction when you add people
to your team um there's the mythical man
month I'm not sure if you've read that
book very very interesting but tell us
about the story yeah all right so um
i' I'm I'm originally from the UK
and the first business I did being in
finance is a very competitive
environment um no one sort of ever wrote
me a huge Angel check and and got me
started it wasn't the case that I was
able to be in the right place at the
right time uh but instead I had to
compete and it was only through being
very efficient uh really adding a lot of
value that the first business was able
to grow and be successful successful and
what I repeatedly saw I would often say
to people I'd say if you are in a market
uh if you are the fifth best you'll make
no money at all if you're like the third
best you'll just about pay the bills and
all of the rewards go to really that
first best and the second best players
in the market and so everything that
I've done in my professional life I've
always strived to um either be the best
be in the top two and I would only ever
attempt to do something if I thought I'd
really be adding a lot of value to that
uh problem or that market and so in my
experience I started off as a selft um
software engineer selft coder selft a
self-taught machine learner and I would
start off just writing code by myself
and and everyone who started off writing
code by themselves um is very messy
there's code everywhere it's not well
organized it's a very chaotic thing but
actually when it's just your yourself
interacting with that codebase it works
quite well and then what happens is as
soon as you introduce someone else in
into this messy codebase suddenly um
your velocity kind of halves You by
adding a person to the team the amount
you get done halves because suddenly
you're just tripping over one another's
toes the whole time um they make a
change to the code over here and
something strange happens over there um
and vice versa and so you have to begin
learning uh techniques to deal with this
complex
and in software
engineering understanding the nature of
this complexity and navigating it well
is is a there's a huge literature on it
and very very smart people have have
come up with some really great solutions
to this one of which is writing really
good unit tests others is having things
like
get the task at hand solved but they'll
do it in a way which increases the
complexity of the overall system and and
the cost of complexity is exponential so
you can add a little bit more a little
bit more and then suddenly everything is
breaking and every time you add a new
feature the app crashes or the trading
engine crashes um or and so in my
experience I found the only people who
really uh stayed on top of complexity
were able to reduce it were people
people who were creative who were
intelligent and people who had very high
standards and really wanted uh to cut
through the complexity wanted to
challenge themselves and they would be
the ones who would come up to me and say
well will why don't we switch paradigms
here why don't we instead of doing it in
this way where we have to keep adding
more and more and more we could actually
flip the way we do it have a single
thing and it'll be much
simpler um and and I found that whenever
I worked with these people the amount of
value that they would add would the the
things that they would do time would
really prove its worth and when in the
moment you say that looks good A year
later I would say wow that that thing
that you did added so much value that
the whole company was able to build on
top of it and it made them more
efficient and so on and so this
experience in in a really uh competitive
environment gave me a very strong
opinion on how I think how I thought
this consumer startup should look like
and how I thought we should approach the
uh the engineering behind the AI
and I was very very confident that we
are in a unique period of time where a
lot of people will look at the startups
produced in the 2000s and the 2010s and
they would kind of see like this these
these teams that would require headcount
to to grow and I always say with
Facebook and with eBay uh and Google
these guys they had to buy Hardware they
had to stick it in their garage they had
to manage a cluster and they they had to
do so much work so much heavy liftin
just to run a
website whereas today we're able to I
can use Google cloud and and and gcp is
this fantastic thing which I would have
to have 30 Engineers to recreate just
10% of it right we're able to use um a
cloud provider called core weave who who
they they currently manage our thousand
GPU cluster for us how many Engineers
would would I have to do to to to have
that and then all of the tooling on top
of it such as kubernetes Docker python
um there are a lot higher level
abstractions and so just having 12
really talented really dedicated
creative Engineers who can work well as
a team I think have this incredible
amount of Leverage Far Far More Than
People realize um and and and just this
pressure to add headcount or it feels
bigger you that it feels like safety is
in a numbers but actually if you add
people to the team who who aren't who
aren't real Superstars it just slows
things down they create Havoc um and so
really I've always had a lot of
discipline uh when it comes to hiring
and building uh a team and insisting on
having very very high Talent density
yeah I I'll just very quickly do a
follow-up on this because I'm it's so
interesting to me um there's this book
called broken code and that talks all
about the challenges that meta had in
their growth and of course they had this
little book they gave out to people and
they said you know move fast and break
things and you know trying to maintain
that dynamism and um I think it's it's a
bit of a cultural thing so apparently on
the Facebook workplace the engineers
hate this notion that there's all of
these Heroes creating disasters and then
cleaning up after it so on the one hand
you could be quite autocratic and very
steady and on the other hand you could
be kind of throwing things away fixing
things quickly and when they complexify
start again what's your position on that
so um I I'm a I'm a big Advocate and a
big believer in common sense
and I think that on the one hand we can
imagine these very bureaucratic entities
uh big Tech where to deploy the code
it's got to pass through several reviews
um once you have a tremendously
successful company such as Google uh
produces a hell of a lot of money the
mindset becomes do not break it right we
don't have to do anything crazy here
guys we got a good thing going do not
mess this up um and it makes a lot of
sense to be very conservative and you
see the organization and the culture
shift towards that chai startups uh
companies that want to rapidly grow
companies um at chai I say guys we are
you know we need to keep growing every
year we need to grow by a factor of
three every couple years we need to goow
by factor of 10 we need to take huge
risks we need to be innovating and
basically I say that's why startups
exist if we do not take risks there is
no point in us um big companies exist to
be efficient and to maximize profits and
to just pay everyone well and to serve a
product to Consumers that the users
expect and are happy with stops are
there to take risk to innovate and
create something new so you absolutely
have to have this this this push this
move fast and break things it's so easy
to be comfortable it's so easy to wake
up in the morning chai chai currently
has about a million people use the app
every day and it's so easy to just feel
comfortable with that feel that's a
pretty big number that's pretty good
let's just um let's let's keep that
smooth and then to start taking small
smaller steps and smaller steps and less
less risk um but instead I encourage
people so often people will come to me
and say will is it okay if I do this I
say look you're smarter than me you've
got a PhD in mathematics I'm a lowly uh
Economist you're you're smart than I am
if you think it's a good idea just do it
what's you know if something explodes if
something breaks up you can just undo
it's software right there's very few
things in software that is permanent and
so on the one hand you really have to
encourage and nurture and push for this
drive to keep innovating and keep taking
risks by the way the only way you learn
something is by taking a risk through
experimenting and many many times you
know if we look through history the
biggest and best Innovations have kind
of been these uh these accidents so you
need accidents to happen uh so that's
the one half of it on the other hand you
know it's very simple if you have if you
imagine a really messy room and you know
these creative people people that are
overly creative it's very easy for them
to create big messes and then once
things get in such a messy State it's
hard to be productive it's hard to just
do good work anyway and so it really
requires a lot of discipline to do
things in a rigorous way if you want to
do an experiment are you going to do a
write up are you going to be explicit
about your hypothesis are you going to
capture the data are you going to
capture good quality data are you going
to interview you users um and it's a lot
of stuff that's very very very tedious
and it's not very exciting um it
requires Great discipline to do the
experiments in a rigorous way um and so
and so it's important to have both and
and neither is easy neither is a natural
impulse what's what's natural is to just
turn up to work and do the easy stuff do
the fun stuff do what's not going to get
you fired and keep your head down that's
what's easy and so push to take risk
have the discipline to do it in a
scalable way and efficient way um if the
code complexity is getting too big set
that month aside refactor it tackle it
um I think it's those two things it's
the discipline alongside the risk Tak in
and you can't just have one if you just
have discipline it works if you're
Google it doesn't work if you're a
startup if you just have the risk taken
without the discipline what does that
look like it either looks like FTX or it
looks like a company that builds one
cool product once and then never again
yeah and I I think there's a really
interesting relationship between risk
taking and creativity and creativity is
a strange piece because it must be
grounded by some kind of intuition about
what's right but it does appear quite
random but you know with with the eye on
the time um so you're you're building
this exciting startup and you haven't
told us what you do yet so what do you
do okay awesome um so so we started off
uh as simply a consumer app um and back
in the days when there were only a few
language models available uh chai began
building our own language model uh we
optimized it for entertainment and then
we served it to users um and people
loved they came they interacted with it
they loved playing games with it talking
to it whether that's for therapy whether
that's for help on their homework um and
then what we saw was we saw there was
this big wave of Open Source and that
was when we got very excited and we were
able to to kind of really step into uh
the initial Vision which was to be this
big plan platform a big aggregator where
we could have researchers data
scientists software Engineers there are
so many cool people who are building
language models at home building AI at
home and they've got cool and
interesting models and we get them to
submit their models to our platform um
we have a python package it's called
chivers and we take these models and we
deploy them immediately uh to our users
and the users give the models feedback
um and then that helps the researchers
and the software engineers and the data
scientists to refine their models
whether that's changing the prom
changing the sampling parameters uh
trying a different base model uh
cleaning their data sets um and the best
models kind of float to the top and then
we give them money um so we've paid out
about
$150,000 so far um we intend to pay out
about a third of our Revenue that would
put us in line with companies like
YouTube um these uh ugc platforms and we
really we we really want to be able to
um combine this huge array um of unique
and specialized language models into an
an experience and a like a single meta
model um that would vastly uh surpass
any individual
model yeah um so we spoke earlier about
partitioning the value in language
models so of course you know one one one
school of thought is it's the model it's
the neuron Network another school of
thought is it's the data and and I think
you're leaning into that and even then
there's a there's a kind of partition of
the data it was trained on the data it
was fine tuned on the um the feedback
cycle with the customers it sounds like
you're really leaning into that yep so
um I absolutely am a huge advocate for
the research that openai did um between
2018 and all the way up until when they
released chat GPT which was I guess
2023 um or 2022 even uh they they were
so transparent they were so open and
they did amazing research and they've
got all these papers which demonstrate
that as you increase the size of the
model the general capabilities scale
well and scale uh reliably so if you
just if you don't know what you're doing
you can absolutely always increase your
model and it will get smarter uh but if
you have anything that's sort of
specific in the least it's clear that
fine-tuning the model uh way increases
the performance way more than making it
bigger so they were able to get a a 1.5
billion parameter model to outperform 80
billion parameter model for reasonably
broad tasks through fine-tuning after
you find fine tuned you would do
reinforcement learning and then of
course you've got prompt engineering and
so the way I currently think of it is
you've got uh the base model fine-tuned
reinforcement learning and prompt
engineering and and you can put um
instruction training in there as well if
you want and it's very very clear that
if if we live in a world where there are
individuals who have a very strong idea
very strong understanding they're able
to select and generate data sets for a
very specific thing uh they're able to
format the prompts do reinforcement
learning they will be able to get
behavior on a single Dimension to
surpass or match very very high human
performance but the amount of energy the
amount of dedication the amount of
creativity and experimentation it takes
to just achieve that that sliver is not
uh it's it's a distributed thing it's a
distributed thing it's a thing that's
best left to small teams and you
actually see it already you see these
research Labs where I think this week
there was a language model that was
trained only on astrophysics and it's
like Astro Lama and it's it's it's it
claims to be uh the best in the world at
dealing with as astrophysics questions
great so it was a team a small team of
researchers who built this amazing one
if there's a thousand of these if
there's 10 thousands of these
distributed um across earth uh how can
we bring them all together to form an
amazing llm that outperforms something
that that a monolithic company such as
Google or open AI would produce yeah
that really resonates with me so I'm
excited about this idea of an agent
framework where you can have experts in
particular things but it's not just the
agent plane it's the data plane because
you know there's this um copyright
Fiasco at the moment and I think in the
future that there'll be some kind of um
way of federating access to copyright
content so I can say well I've paid to
have access to this science journal so I
want to do retrieval augmented
generation with this because I've paid
for it so surely it has to go that way I
think it's important to recognize uh in
my life I've always seen that people are
rewarded in proportion to the value that
they truly bring and so I would argue a
huge Corpus of kind of random text
intrinsically is not that a valuable
thing uh it's the curating it it's the
fine-tuning the models with the right
parameters the right
regularization right EPO the right
Optimizer that's where the value ad is
is is occurring on the on the
fine-tuning and the and the pre-training
layer then we've got this prompt
engineering we've got this retrieval
that's obviously a huge value ad as well
and so I think it's very clear that in
the future there will be a market for uh
data retrieval and I'm sure the New York
Times will make a lot of money when
language model providers start
subscribing to the upto-date New York
Times data feed they'll make a lot of
money doing that I find it hard to
imagine a world where the New York Times
rightfully should be able to get a lot
of money for their old works the out
ofate works it's intrinsically not that
valuable not many people are using this
stuff
and the value is really being added by
these data scientists so I think it's
important to have a have a separation
between the two this timely this
up-to-date information this this data
set that people are going to want to
retrieve from um this prompt engineering
side and then this this fine-tuning this
pre-training which this the data
scientists who are adding all of the
value I agree and we don't have time to
get into it but I I think um copyright
protects the expression not the idea and
GPT has a Charisma bypass so there's
there's no copyright infringement you
might argue whereas mid Journey that
there is but um just um just just to
finish off though will this has been
really amazing what's coming next for
you where can people find out about you
and and what kind of challenges are you
working with So currently chivers decom
this platform uh for for aggregating
language models it's a competition
people are free to submit any model uh
and if it's a good model we reward them
financially it takes talented Engineers
to build this stuff if we are going to
keep growing if we are going to be able
to really leverage all of Human
Resources um to building the next step
in AI um yeah just hiring so if if
someone's an in a great engineer whether
that's researching whether that's uh
python whether that's um just back end
uh apply to Chai uh and yeah that's
that's that's that's really why I'm here
is is to help um promote what we doing
to attract talented Engineers to work
with us well it's been an absolute honor
to have you on mlst thank you so much
for joining us today thanks thanks Tim